yeah hello welcome to this video it's a
new episode of endgame basics yeah I had
this game the end game series is
continuing with some basic endgame
queen against single porn yeah seems
overwhelming with the Queen against the
pawn but it's not that easy
in many situations in fact the pawn the
long pawn will draw if circumstances are
right in this particular position that
we have in front of us in fact is
winning for the Queen but it's important
to know the differences what positions
are winning what positions are drawn of
course there are very simple cases a
very simple case would be whether pawn
it's not yet on the seventh rank yeah
we're this far back in this case is the
Queen is winning fairly easily and also
without you having to know anything
special you will just stop the pawn
get the King die and we'll checkmate it
is more interesting if the pawn is one
step away from promotion here on the
seventh rank or here the second rank in
case of of this black example with the
pawn um in this case pawn on the seventh
rank there are various factors that come
into consideration um one is what porn
is it yeah
is it a central pawn yeah a bishop spawn
an iPod or rook pawn this is all
different of course there's a mirror
image of this doesn't matter it is the G
pollen or the b-pawn in this case this
is why it's sometimes useful to column
rook pawn Knight pawn bishop spawn umm
yeah this is a factor and the second
important thing is the position of the
king of the site that has the Queen the
King far away obviously is a
disadvantage it's better to have the
king somewhere near the pawn that's him
let's look at this case first that the
king is far away um in this case it is
pretty straightforward
because you can easily tell the result
from the tab of the pawn
if it is a night pot so G&B pawn or one
of the central pawns it is a win for the
Queen excite for the Queen side um if it
is a bishops pawn or a rook pawn so of
those it is a draw
why is that let's have a look the wide
winning procedure is identical for B G
and central pawns what the Queen needs
to do is it always have to give checks
or stop the pawn from promotion in this
case we start with a check here
Black's King doesn't want to step in
front of the pawn that makes sense you
want to promote it so black will step to
the side and now the important thing is
white will attack that pawn force King
to f1 and check again and this is a key
position now the King cannot um avoid
stepping in front of the pawn has to
step to G 1 otherwise the pawn gets
taken and this is the important moment
now
the white king can approach you've got
one crucial tempo to approach black will
of course try to get them and get out of
this situation
yeah but the thing is something like
this will still win it's the same
procedure it's a pin this is very simple
yeah if you just step in front of it
it's very simple the king will come
around and this pawn will be picked up
so king h1 and with a check King g1
again you gain a crucial tempo and from
that it's relatively easy to understand
you just do this all over again yeah can
checks check and then oops
you approach yeah and it gets nearer and
nearer um for example here um you can
already go to a straight winning
procedure with King edge
for us this is a checkmate so quite nice
yeah something like this is king forward
and Nate gets a mate with the king near
it's very easy this is Sam as I said the
procedure for the central pawns and the
knight pawn if you're not we can also
look quickly at the central pawn it is
just the same thing just a second yeah
quick look how the central pawn works
it's just the same thing we start with
checks check check check check check
check
and again unavoidable you have to step
in front of that pawn and then the King
approaches it's exactly the same
procedure
note that maybe if you look at this
position with with a table base with the
computer it might give you some quicker
Winningham CJ I'm just putting the moves
out as I would play them it's
necessarily the quickest way to do it
but it's a safe and very straightforward
way to do it yeah so please don't expect
that I'm doing this perfectly I just
want to show that it is relatively easy
to do once you understand the mechanism
like here and again you can do stuff
like that check and approaches yeah yeah
here this it already looks like there
should be some direct meat available um
is there one don't see it don't see it
at the mode so probably we will continue
with our standard procedure a little bit
and and do it to do it like this this
for example is quite quite cute we can
play here yeah because this is checkmate
made if the king is near there are many
of those direct checkmates um so this is
nice but what about the rook pawn and
the bishops pawn yeah this is a typical
position with the bishops pawn what is
the difference to the G pawn or the
central pawn
well why we'll start exactly in exactly
the same way okay that's not necessary
no I don't need to step step them check
yeah something like this yeah okay now
I'm going here what is the big point
let's say here yeah and now this is
threatened and why it has to do
something check check this is the this
is the key moment in this precise
position where this check is played in
the other situation now and the pawn is
on the G follow in the central finds
black is forced to go here and cannot
drop his pawn yeah he has to keep his
pawn I mean it has to step in front of
it and then the King is advancing he
however due to the edge of the board
situation the black King can go King
edge one and if white is Stanley exactly
yeah stalemate is the problem the edge
of the board is the deciding factor here
and let's black draw this
the thing is white has still move here
really you can only check now you can
check and we go back and again we
threaten this and it's a straight
straight forward draw there's really
nothing to do the bishop on draws very
easily due to this stalemate Rick what
about the rook pawn yeah here we have a
typical rook pawn situation and again
the problem is this stalemate due to the
edge of the board if white checks him
and that King will hide in the corner
and in this situation there is a
stalemate and white really has no choice
he has to withdraw from that situation
here from that position and yeah I'll
give a check check black goes back and
again he threatens one I mean where else
can you go well I know somewhere here
and he has black girls and threatens and
well you have to give checks and it's
always a stalemate there it's absolutely
nothing I'll get it
my penis more a bit more sensible
threatening again to promote this
stalemate Rick is saving the day for
black yeah you have no square to go to
so these are very straightforward things
to remember if the White King the king
it's right you ever decide with the
Queen the king is very far away then the
bishops pawns Bishop pawns Andrew pawns
they they draw due to the stalemate
ideas GNB porn the knight pawns and the
central pawns do win for the Queen it's
pretty straightforward
the tricky situations arise when the
White King is somewhat nearer yeah here
we have it on the eighth rank of highway
sounds rank but if the king is nearer
things are far more interesting let's
look at a couple of situations yeah here
we have a situation typical of that
scenario the White King here is far
nearer the action and in this case white
in fact can win but how exactly okay
we're going to start with a check check
and the King has to go to g1 there is no
other Square this is very simple here we
can I mean there are probably quicker
ways but yeah the simplest to understand
is that the queen is just blocking the
pawn king h1 is a checkmate direct made
so here and now we see the key the key
moment the problem is that after
promotion black will be checkmated this
is the key idea J and now it is black
smooth but it's such an unfortunate
position here off those two pieces then
really black has no way out
this Queen f2 mate and Queen e1 mate and
really black has no way to do anything
about it yeah I can just disparado his
Queen and get Shaq made two or three
moves later this is a win by checkmate
so is this the only way to win No
there is a second way actually and this
is king - III in this situation again if
the promotion is happening checkmate
it's made it's very nice it's also motif
to remember because there are cases
maybe where you don't have this route
available maybe let's say the king is
here yeah then you only have this this
way to win so that's that's nice to
remember there are also yes so called
winning zones yeah where the king can be
in order to have to have it being a win
and you can try to remember those to be
honest I never really got got to that to
remember the exact winning zone the only
thing that I do know is if I'm near the
whole thing I have to remember those two
mating ideas and see if I can get them
in yeah this is usually enough here for
example if the king if we altered this
position a little bit yeah like here
it's obvious that is the same thing yeah
because well I can't go here where I
need to need to be to win here like this
would be the same winning position that
we already know yeah however if the
white king is even further away we see
that it's still a win because something
exists which is the same if you are even
further away then it will get tricky you
need to be able to go here or here and
this would be like from here here here
and so on yeah so you can sort of puzzle
this together but I never really
bothered to learn the exact look of that
that winning someone important is to
remember the mating ideas alright now
look let's look at a position with the
bishops pawn and the king near the pawn
here is also typical winning maneuver
available what white needs to do here is
to pin the idea is that after well king
king f1 is easier which is
approach but after this the ideas that
king g3 will wind because and after the
promotion
checkmate there is a mate we've seen a
similar made already earlier from a
position where the King had advanced
this is very important to know of those
mating ideas sometimes in a game when
you have little time it's very useful to
know that how the mates look like so
then you can find them much much quicker
there are a couple of versions of those
mates yeah for example another one yeah
let's look at let's look at this
position there's more than one way to do
it but one can motif that is worth
remembering is the following
yeah again we give a couple of checks
and yeah here for example here this is
an interesting one checkmate mate this
mate is also worth to remember it can
happen in a couple of shapes and sizes
for example if we think about this for
example let's go here check yeah then
this is a nice move to take into account
again
checkmate this is a mate yeah ok now
let's look at a final position to sum
things up yeah what about what about
this position here um Jack Queen me 3
check King a 1 yeah note the stalemate
stalemate yeah okay so what what exactly
can why - we can do this yeah use the
pin and now this is an interesting
little position here what should black
do now that's very important black has
to move the King and where to go the
thing is that King b1 is unfortunately
losing due to this check and again the
parade with a with a meeting idea yeah
note that there's absolutely no way for
black to save this what should like do
it I mean let's say here yeah
checkmate yeah there's a mate possible
mate here here and on the first rank so
black has no way to keep all that
covered it runs can very easily happen
king b1 the trick is of course you have
to go here yeah again with the stalemate
and now something like this yeah check
and now you have a check and we really
draw ya note that check this is a neat
way Stanley to force matters entirely
yeah so there are always always little
tricks that you have to remember here
with Queen and porn and the king is near
those meeting ideas can be exceptionally
tricky to face when you have the pawn if
you have the King if you if you have the
the Queen against this pawn you always
should be aware of those those tricks if
the king is near there are often chances
for those to stalemates and damage for
this mating eating patterns to occur
yeah I hope you enjoyed it I think it's
it's very useful to have seen some of
those ideas it will definitely get you
many points or saved half points or 1/2
points especially in quick time control
games where you don't have time to work
it out for yourself I hope you enjoyed
it thanks for watching